Speaker 1: In the meantime, there there are
now multiple reports, which is why I'm ready
to bring it to you. Multiple reports
that Russia has bombed kindergartens
and orphanages in Ukraine, potentially committing
war crimes. There's a report from Ilia Laszewski,
a writer and senior editor for the Organized Crime
and Corruption Reporting Project, who tweeted
Quote reports that a Ukrainian kindergarten
used as a shelter was hit. I will not share
the images as they are too graphic. Absent
an extremely compelling explanation,
hard to imagine what it could be. This is a war
crime. This was later apparently corroborated by
Dmytro Kuleba, the Minister of Foreign Affairs
of Ukraine, who tweeted, quote today's Russian
attacks on kindergartens and orphanages are
war crimes and violations of the Rome Statute.
Together with the Office of the Attorney General,
we are collecting these and other materials
which we will immediately transfer to The
Hague. Responsibility is inevitable. Now
we can't dismiss, and the reason I keep saying
this is because this way it has happened already.
We can't dismiss the possibility that someone
is mistaken here or that this is somehow not as
reported. But there are now multiple reports
and corroboration, even from Ukrainian state
officials, that there have been bombings of
kindergartens and orphanages. And of course, you
know, all of the bombing is wrong. That's going
on here. The sovereignty of Ukrainian borders
is being violated. This is a this is a aggressive
action from Putin. All of those things are true.
In addition, if indeed there are bombings of
kindergartens and orphanages taking place,
then it makes it all the more horrifying. And
it will likely take no matter how much longer
this all goes on, and it could be two days.
It could be two weeks. It could be two months,
probably not more than two months at this. At this
level of escalation would be my guess. No matter
how long it takes. Much like with the Trump
administration, where it will take years to
unwind, everything that happened, it will likely
take a long time to find out everything that has
taken place over the last week in Ukraine. Let me
know where your mind is on what you expect to see
over the next few days here. Find me on Twitter at
De Packman. Let me know. We'll take a quick break.